- I heard this about you,
which I think is funny
'cause it seems late in the game
to learn how to pluck your eyebrows,
but Tina Fey taught you?
(Amy laughs)
- She did.
- When did she did she teach
you how to pluck your eyebrows?
I'm like, how long have
you known each other?
- What if I was like 44?
- I was like, it seemed late in the game.
Like, when did y'all
meet and this happened?
- We were probably, at that point,
we were probably touring for Second City.
So I was in my twenties for sure.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- [Amy] Yeah, I was in
my twenties for sure.
- For some reason in my brain,
I just see y'all meeting
at 30 and you were like
so how do you do this?
- No, you know Tina and
Maya who I do baking with
and like we've all now known
each other for 25 years almost.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah, Rachel Dratch,
all those people I met,
but Tina and I met in
Chicago in the nineties,
so yeah, it must have been.
And the nineties was a
different time, you know?
- I feel like people used to
pluck all their eyebrows off
at one point.
- That's true.
- Yes, it was a very thin line.
- I have very, I've
been told, not to brag,
but I've been told I
have very Irish eyebrows,
which means they're hardy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And yeah, they're kind of strong.
- I do too.
- Do you too?
- Yeah, you have to pluck away.
There's a carpet up here.
- That's not a bad thing.
But yeah, in the nineties
it was kind of tough.
Now everyone's like, you know
four day work week and do your
eyebrows however you want.
It's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Again.
- I love it.
We're starting to turn
European with this whole, yeah.
I love that vibe, yeah.
I feel like every time I go to Europe,
they're always on vacation.
I'm like, why did I not grow up here?
I'm like what?
How are you still on vacation?
- You should do Kelly Clarkson in Europe.
And then the entire
week should be no shows.
- We just sit around.
- And you just have wine.
- Will you come to that show
and just hang out with wine?
- And we walk around
and we film it just one
hour a day and you're like,
this is it.
- We're in Europe and now siesta,
we're gonna go take a nap.